[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on
very excited to be talking about music
production we have Nikko core lock
joining us hello hello thanks so much
for coming on the show absolutely
anytime super excited for this
Nikko I'm so happy we ran into each
other when we were at boost VC doing the
interview with Tim Draper wandered
downstairs and I saw you and you were
sitting there working on some adaptive
music for I think was for me you at that
point and I was like whom adaptive music
they do what's this dude dude yeah yeah
and here we are on the show together
photos that don't know Nico's background
Nico core logs a graduate of San
Francisco Conservatory of Music with the
background in classical and electronic
music composition and game audio
implementation his clients have included
oculus razor and a slew of independent
game developers and filmmakers he's also
an accomplished pop producer you can
find the links in the bio below to Nikko
core log music.com as well as a
SoundCloud
and the avila key calm as well alright
Nikolas are things off with one of our
favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world there's just so much going
on it's hard to keep track I try to
listen to NPR and like read all the
political news I think I'm not really
happy with the direction that this
country is going in with the leadership
of our president right now I hope that
Bernie gets elected and I feel like
there are there are so many
possibilities and there's so much
technology and there's so many
initiatives that are pushing the world
in a better direction things like
self-driving cars and
research into fusion that I feel like
could balance out some of the negativity
that's going on like in the Middle East
and the Huawei thing in China and but
it's like we don't know what's gonna
work and what's not and everybody I
guess is just trying to do their best to
make the world a better place so yeah
there's amount of times that we've asked
that question and the answer has been
that oh we both live in a dystopia and a
utopia right I mean it's a dystopia for
some people and a utopia for others and
I think that that it's probably
everybody's responsibility to kind of
close that gap yeah yeah and we always
like to make it like if the current
status of like the richest in the world
in the poorest in the world are like
this let's say it doesn't have to be
that they the rich have to come down it
can be that the poorest come up if I'm
just faster with them yeah the pie gets
yeah there's there's a concept that some
governments are exploring which is
universal basic income and I think that
could potentially I mean there are two
sides of that I don't know that much
about it but I think that it has the
potential to to kind of equalize things
but it also has the potential to like
create inflation so like finding a
balance between those things and trying
to maybe you know tax the rich more and
raise minimum wage and that kind of
thing would be fantastic yeah yeah yeah
this is a good kickoff to the convos
let's jump into the journey so you're
born in Redwood City here in the Bay
Area in the park or actually Stanford
Hospital oh you're born at Stanford ah
so but grew up in yeah redwood city yeah
okay this general area this general area
yes yes how did you pick up your
interest in music it's a good question
one that I've thought about a lot there
were a lot of influences in my early
life that led me to a path of music
namely my parents exposing me to all
sorts of music when I was a kid
my mother would take me to the symphony
she would play marching games with me
like rhythm instruments just all sorts
of little music things that she just
thought were an enriching experience and
turned out to be like my formative
music training that said she always
thought it was a good idea to learn an
instrument so when I was in kindergarten
first grade I started taking piano
lessons before school once a week and
just continued that for a couple of
years and then eventually went to start
taking voice lessons I got bored with
piano and then after voice lessons I
kind of like rediscovered the piano and
started like noodling around and trying
to figure stuff out by ear and like
hearing songs on the radio and trying to
like copy them and that turned into like
absorbing all of those musical patterns
to where I realize I could like take
those patterns and like experiment with
them and build my own music with them
and so it's just like expanded from
there it was like yeah the influences of
things like going to the symphony or
things like even just playing around
with a parent just for parents to be
able to to inspire their kids to venture
into sound in that way I think so
important it's such something that comes
with it's such a major part of our
evolutionary origin story as well and
then okay so piano and singing we're big
and then you kind of figured out that
you could like take pieces and like
remix them yourself and start yeah yeah
I mean it started with very simple like
was the name of that song
famous slow dance song right here
waiting was the first thing that I
learned on the piano is like a really
simple like 151 left hand line and a
melody in the right hand and that was a
pattern that I could like take and move
around the keyboard and like experiment
with and yeah and and that's like the
core of everything that I do right now
like when I work on a game soundtrack or
something I listen to somebody else's
music hear what the patterns are and
look take it play with it turn it into
my own thing so yeah that's such a great
way to be able to to both have an an
input stream from people that you
consider leaders or that you think are
doing really good job and then to output
your own take on what you took in and
yeah yeah I mean that is actually one of
the best ways to learn is to like really
critically study other people's music
people at the top of their field and
like take their techniques and make them
your own that's basically how I learned
everything that's like that that
principle like in education itself is
such a big one to find the leaders in
the field that you aspire to be
successful in and learn from them watch
them very carefully take lots of notes
be a student and yet remix
yeah yeah yeah and when I was at
conservatory I got to study with some
like really successful kind of
well-known ish
video game composers and sitting down
and watching their process and listening
to them talk about how they went about
their own music was like a big part of I
think there was an assignment that I had
to do weekly which was like listen to a
track right could be anything
it's like video game music or like pop
song or like a hip hop tune or whatever
take that track and like recreate it
from scratch and so that I would credit
to you know I would credit that with
giving me the ability to be as versatile
as I am because studying all sorts of
different kinds of music it was
basically forced upon us so yeah yeah
and this is something else that I think
so interesting and I highly recommend
people to go to Nikko SoundCloud profile
and go take a listen to some of the
music but it's so diverse and I it's
everything from pop to film scores to
video game pieces like I love it it's
all over the place and in all in a lot
of like we were listening to pump
earlier and now that wasn't what was
play at the beginning but we were
listening to it beforehand and pump is
so good it's very ancient I love that
aspect to it I'm a very big romantic of
the past that is sir
so let's take it take us into the
sanford sub conservatory of music days
okay so you're giving us a little bit of
that what even is is that like so it's
located here by the Civic yeah yeah
right nearby
Lepore there gem of San Francisco you're
like 400 students 400 so it's not a very
big school in our year for year there
there's a four-year degree and they're a
bunch of different programs there's like
performance and teaching and
jazz there's a new jazz program there
percussion all sorts of classical
instruments the program that I was a
part of is called tack which is the
technology and applied composition
program basically a four year bachelor's
degree that teaches you the basics of
how to be a media composer with a with a
focus on video game music so we studied
all sorts of stuff at one point I was
taking like three music history classes
at the same time along with musicianship
and theory and private composition
lessons it was just like a really
intense educational experience a lot of
work a lot of late nights I learned a
lot I met a lot of really great people
but yeah the TAC program is new it was
new in the year 2015 and they're making
all sorts of connections with industry
professionals and sending students to
China for a kind of immersion cultural
exchange kind of trips and that kind of
thing so yeah it's a it's a program to
look out for it there are already a
couple of pretty successful students who
like one is Janna ma who's now a future
based producer and she goes and plays
huge shows in the Bay Area
gets recognized on the street so you can
probably expect a little bit more of
that from the TAC program I don't know
we'll see see how things turn out
I love that okay and then what is it
like then when you're you know going
through so it's ta CA technology and
applied composition technologies hand
applied composition so ta a/c or just
TAC just here yeah technology and
applied composition so when you when you
start learning how to compose I mean you
were obviously doing it a lot as a kid
and like when you go in it's really
obviously heavily benefits to have done
this a lot when you were younger when
you're in there and you're thinking
about different ways to apply it I mean
video games is one of the ways to apply
it but you're doing things like of
course learning from top video game
producers and their soundtracks but also
doing things like even finding things in
music that is not in video games and
applying that yeah as well yeah
absolutely and that's one of the things
about the TAC program that's really
amazing is that it gives all the
students tools that they can take in any
number of directions I was just talking
to one of my friends Chris who's
graduated the TAC program and he was
like there's just so much you can do
with it people can go be media composer
they can write for television they can
write for games they could go be a live
sound engineer at a venue they could
become a mix engineer and record bands
you know they could be pop stars you
know like all of these things and I
think the part of my problem is I I want
to do literally all of those things at
the same time and so like I have musical
ADHD like you see the variety of the
music that I have on my my page it's
like every new piece that I write is a
totally different entity because I just
like I want to do everything so we have
knowledge ad D here we're such a
multi-disciplinary show so I love that
that's funny that you say you say that
and I think that actually ends up
helping you become like a a polymath in
the music space just like we're trying
to be a polymath in the knowledge space
and so I think that a lot of people will
come to you because of that as well that
you're very deep on Brad
so I like that a lot
so okay so then so then when do you
actually start doing things like like
diet like actually diagnosing these you
were teaching you about this Timbers
pallets colors and music we actually
learned from another friend that we
featured surely spikes that she calls it
the biology of sound oh yeah that's
perfect perfect apt description the
biology of sound I went to a lecture the
other night and the the lecturer made it
like a parallel between like the
construction of a whole piece of music
is like similar to the way a the sense
of self is like comprised of different
components that all work together to a
concurrent whole so like yeah biology of
sound makes sense I think what you're
talking about was like Tambor's and
different structures and a lot of
contours and colors and gestures and all
of those are tools and techniques that
are
the that you can invoke you know
depending on what style of music you
want there are different tools and
techniques that I would apply if I'm
working on a pop song that I wouldn't
apply
you know if I'm working on a video game
each one of these different styles that
I work in has its own kind of series of
quirks and so I find it really enjoyable
to like listen to a genre of music and
try to break down like into concrete
like really solid qualities like bass
music for instance okay it has a drum
and bass beat the snare drum sounds it's
a very specific snare drum sound it
sounds like a like a dubstep or drum and
bass snare there's a super low sub bass
that is always a huge round sine wave
but then you know there's often like a
gritty modulated thing on top like all
of these things are qualities of that
specific type of music and so like
having a comprehensive knowledge of like
what qualities make for a good track in
a specific genre is really important if
you want to be able to write music and a
bunch of different styles and I'm always
trying to learn and build that library
as I go along because and you know every
time I get a new gig it's something
different there's always stuff to learn
and this would be maybe good to show the
digital audio or say yeah yeah well so
let's show that and break this down
because they're I think a good way to
describe it is to actually show these
little there what do you call these
little um are they like what you call
like a little mock module or what yeah
these are regions regions their regions
so this is a MIDI region this line here
is one MIDI note oh yeah so what is MIDI
stands for musical instrument digital
interface so it's a way of taking data
from like a keyboard and sending it to a
MIDI module which actually makes sound
or digital audio workstations use it to
control instruments and so for instance
this here oh if it doesn't lag on me is
a synthesizer this MIDI data here is
sent to this which sends sends output to
the stereo output bus and so any any
track that I work on has like 15 20 50
100 tracks each one of having an
instrument okay so what what is every
what what is every row that we see is
that a different that's a different
answer that's so every rows a different
instrument and then the and then when
you click into one of those little
regions yeah then you can change the
actual notes and then you can change the
notes in that region know up and down
move the note up and down like you know
yeah yeah like white play play it in oh
yeah move it between that range of
really high to really low absolutely and
you can actually you know zoom
zoom out so you can see like that's
always c- to to c8 yeah
and then you pick your you're picking
how how often it's appearing that note
or what variation of that note and then
you're stacking all the different
instruments yes
damn yeah yeah yeah I mean it's a lot of
work get fast at it if you do it a
couple hours every day yeah how do you
know well first of all is is this
Ableton no this is a this is logic
I had logic have an old version of
Ableton on this regime so so logic
Ableton these are kind of basic Ableton
pro tools performer Cubase they all
basically do the same thing in different
ways and then and then is is the like it
looks like there's a little like library
on the I don't use that that's that's
for selecting like pre-created patches
recreate usually I try and either select
a library that I've bought or program
Lyon sounds so like the stock logic
sounds they're they're okay for
beginners yeah okay and then how would
you how would you go about doing
something like taking a an idea
sure and turning that into music for
your video game a film like all these
different options pop song um it's a
different process every time a lot of
the time that includes me sitting down
at the piano and improvising and like
making up themes and riffs and chord
progressions and then eventually taking
those memorizing them and
moving them to the digital audio
workstation and then kind of fleshing
them out with the sound palette that
I've chosen for that particular piece
sometimes like there's this this
particular project I'll play like a
little bit of it yeah this this
particular project is here that Ronnie
yeah great it's like an ambient piece
based on a mixed media art piece and so
the process for this one is a little bit
different than what I just described
because a lot of the sounds that I've
chosen are based on like my impression
of what the media looks like so like
black lines that branch off sound like
sticks so I'll use the recording of a
stick whiteness sound like snow I'll use
footsteps crunching in snow
[Music]
so for this particular piece I feel like
the art is not in even the result but
the art is in like inventing a new
process that creates its its I approach
it almost scientifically yeah so there's
like a recipe
it's like parts of the idea you may be
trying like break down parts of the idea
and you're like okay what's the sign to
the art that I need to do with music to
make yeah for that specific part of the
idea and then you like toy and tinker
and get that part and then you're like
okay well what about this next part of
the idea and science and art to figure
out yeah yeah you got hit the nail
that's this is so good because that's
also we talk about this so much but
anyone that's playing the game of life
for the trophy is missing the point of
the game because the game is about the
journey about the process and that's why
it's so important to keep up of really
just like a an attitude of like divinity
that we're here being in nerve ending of
God experiencing itself and meaning to
follow our purpose and remember Adam sir
and be in love with that process I love
that and then now okay well now give us
the give us the bit on like this is
really tough because you know you're
teaching me a bit about this when we
first talked but like for all these
different games that people play like
you know when we're when we're sitting
there playing a game we don't typically
think about
oh I've walked and like closer to a
certain object and all of a sudden I'm
hearing that object louder right that's
the adapt so so that's that's the idea
behind adaptive music is that in video
games you may not be aware of it while
you're playing a video game but the
music is usually if not always
dynamically changing
what you're doing and where you are and
to to do something like that is very
different from writing like a piece of
music that starts here and ends here you
know a piece of adaptive music for a
video game has many layers and loops and
transitions and the way that I like to
conceptualize adaptive music is like not
like a movie but like a flowchart where
each zone or each character or each
action has a different theme they all
kind of flow into each other and can
loop back and it's actually a useful way
of describing a piece of adaptive music
before you've created and it's actually
drawing out a flowchart of different
areas and how the music is going to
interact so that you can know you know
this transition has to work with these
two loops
[Applause]
so yeah yeah some of the the software
that we use for adaptive music is F mod
and W wise both of which take
information from a game engine that's
actually running the game and use that
information to change levels and change
transitions and change all sorts of
modulate able parameters while the game
is actually running this is such an
important lesson in how things work to
be able to dive deeper into like you
literally tie potentially a piece of
looping music around an object in the
game and then possible people walk
that's it really hear louder for one of
one of many things that can be done when
you're talking it seems a tie a loop to
an area or tie a loop to you know your
teammate or oh yeah like all sorts of
different ways and different
combinations and Ashley's are so
complicated yeah yeah I mean it's a
little bit like a puzzle yeah but like
this whole this whole field is like this
organic mosh of like different
techniques and different sounds and
different
and and you have to like take all these
ideas and like mold them to fit whatever
project you're working on at that given
time so yeah and also it totally feels
like when we're outside you know on the
street and there's cars driving by the
vet in a sense is the car audio being
yeah yeah I mean bird chirp audio being
push I I I'm not gonna talk about it
live right now but I've been like doing
a little bit of thinking and
experimentation about like gamifying
music and applying adaptive music in the
real world outside of video games which
I think once it catches on if it catches
on people will be surprised when the
music doesn't change based on what they
doing what they're oh damn cool I mean
that's that's like a crazy
pie-in-the-sky prediction I don't know
how things are gonna work out but yeah
it's already in a sense kind of like
that with wherever you are and whatever
you're doing the music is changing in
the back yeah yeah it to be to have it
be specifically be designed and
engineered for you have a beautiful
experience in a specific location ok so
right now I think right now the way that
music is used in like commercial venues
and stores and whatever is to manipulate
the consumer right and if that
experience was interactive if it
responded the consumer the consumer
would feel like they're in control right
and it would be more personalized
yeah so I think there's a lot of
possibility like all of these ideas come
from video games right like we'll just
see what happens I don't know if I think
one of the big things is like changing
music like on your Spotify like if
there's an ad be playing an appropriate
song for driving past McDonald's right
when you're in the car
things like that like totally possible
and and totally feasible yeah and yeah
you're giving the corporate ideas don't
give a we got to make money the small
rookies the ideas are like how can you
make it so that you get more spiritual
music that place when you're maybe
exploring a park or oh that doesn't sell
I I would bet you that it does there's a
lot of stuff going on in VR right now
like meditation apps I'm gonna be
working on a a VR like EEG biofeedback
those are awesome they're already really
getting popular into space with it with
adaptive music yeah and when you're when
you're more meditative the music changes
when you're less meditative it changes
you have a range most of right right
right
it's so good yeah so it's really I find
it really interesting there's a lot of
overlap between like spiritual
transcendental community and the VR
community which is like yeah something
that I wouldn't expect because VR is
such a high-tech new toy you'd think it
would be tacky is it but there are a lot
of artists and people who are very
spiritual who are way into VR and
creating the experience and actually
like
creating the scene you know the VR world
right now is like an art scene yeah
right yeah it's a big scene for people
to get their first like people say oh
how hard is it to become like the
world's best jazz musician well how much
easier is it to become the world's first
vrj musician the first VR jazz is
there's a VR jazz musicians yeah look it
up these are the questions that you ask
because some people even go as far as
and say that we the generation
Millennials and Generation Z are the
generation that can be the first in the
virtual and augmented reality spaces
because we're born too early the kids
that are born now and in like the 23rd
2020s or 2030s will be the space
exploration generation so I think it's
kind of interesting that are there any
more on any VR jazz peeps reading eight
is a breakthrough for virtual reality in
classical music I love it hey cool I
love it
like there's a I really gotta get my my
rift up and going again yeah
eight is a so-called mixed reality work
by the Dutch composer Michael Vander Ark
Michael Van jaw so he is he's gonna be
in in textbooks in a hundred years
see that's what's right the first yeah
that's that's great yeah right and
textbooks imagine bootstrapping that
like like it VR becoming like creating
something that teaches people about its
own inception yeah yeah yeah so be the
first I mean that's another great way to
put it is you know be the be as me as
the first and the spaces that are
emerging and and get sharing that with
more kids okay that was a bit on
adaptive music as well I wanna I want to
hear what it was like working with the
artists in like the pop space you were
telling us about this artists that
you've been working with in New York
City that comes out here yeah yeah yes
so I write pop music as kind of my own
personal expression and I have a lot of
fun doing it typically I'll go out to
like open mics and I'll go play a couple
songs on the piano and I'll meet some
singers and I'll if I like somebody's
voice and I'll write a song for them and
they'll come over and record
it would be cool to like do that
professionally but like I said before
there are so many different directions
that I could go with what I've learned
that it's like whatever catches on is
what I'm gonna do and I'll be like
beyond happy to either continue you know
working in games are working in pop or
like doing production work or whatever
why don't we play a little bit of that
pop song let's do it I would love to the
one with Jayden yeah that's a great idea
this is another one of the ones on the
soundcloud page that I highly recommend
listening to
see if I can find it
does that work a little louder about her
I think that's a about
[Music]
during some
what guess let it play through the whole
thing or at least in the second the
second versus the good part
we want to maybe how far in is a second
verse
- that'sthat's
so please
or actually yeah I'll just play the
first first person
he's really good meeting
[Music]
and 20 more seconds
[Music]
yeah rockin hot over there
[Music]
yeah what was the name of that lady but
that's my friend Jaden actually I went
to school with her when I was younger
she lives in New York and whenever she's
in town I just write a song for her and
we record and just hang out it's a good
time that's good stuff that's good stuff
that's that's a good friendship I love
stuff like that these are great stories
for how to engage other young people to
get involved you know picking it up
having parents influence help picking it
up the music at young ages get into
digital audio workstations get into
producing stuff just pick up friends
that are also maybe singing and just
like hey let's compose something
together really good friendship like
that try out videogames try outs film
scores try out absolutely I mean the
possibilities are endless and I I mean
one of music's main functions is
bringing people together right whether
it's going together to a show or playing
a video game together or writing a song
together or having arguments over what
genre the indie pop is better you know
let's will you teach us about what it
was like working with with oculus and
razer like what is it like working with
some of the working very very
interesting very different from working
with a single collaborator or a small
team yeah big corporations move slow
yeah though working with oculus I had a
lot of freedom to work with a bunch of
independent teams that's great
basically what happened was oculus hired
me to write music for demos written by
participants of the oculus launch pad
program and so it's okay I was I was
there to support each one of these teams
to create the sound effects and the
music that best fit
they're their projects so there's a lot
of freedom there and a lot of trying to
interpret what each and every team
wanted and needed for their experience
and what what worked best and there were
times when I had to use my own judgment
like this is not a good idea musically
we should try something like this
because this is what's standard and like
that aesthetics don't match if you want
to have like for instance like anime
soundtrack jazz with like a futuristic
like dystopian fighting game like it
just doesn't really match you know so
like trying to be that dictionary of of
what aesthetically works together with a
particular style yeah interesting
experience I ended up writing an hour
and 15 minutes of music for 15 different
game demos last year well which was yeah
and each one of those games was like a
different style and a different team so
there's a lot of juggling like perfect
for you know ADHD like going between
project to project and having like a
bunch of different stuff to do it was
great
yeah it's a fun time and then what's the
difference between that and then
obviously the teams are much smaller
with like lava Loki right and also with
Moo which I love playing music
mirror me and like be able to change his
color and it's like like the smoothing
algorithm on the pixels we're so
interesting and that was fun we
interviewed Sarah Ashby so it's cool
but I have a look you haven't played
that actually is up on Steam for 399
right now it's a cool story so it said
it's the hypothetical beginning of a
series basically these two kids
are missing their father who we learn
was probably abducted because he had
magical powers and in this experience
you go in and embody a spirit called the
aval okie and you guide these children
through memories and give them insight
into their situation and how to find
their father I think this particular
project is kind of unique because it
blends both 3d animation and tilt brush
animation I don't know if you know about
what tilt orders we have this amazing
tilt brush artist Estella see and she I
think she basically does tilt brush art
professionally like that's what she does
and so she created these like augmented
2d 3d kind of layered beautiful 3d
paintings that you get to experience in
aval okey I highly recommend checking it
out I can talk a little bit about the
soundtrack it was a 20 minute
soundtrack or like 18 and a half minutes
and was written over probably about six
months I recorded live cello live piano
and live argue I found an argue player
yeah there's a an are who it's I hear it
described as the Chinese violin okay and
it's a an instrument that has like kind
of a barrel shaped head and then a neck
with some strings and the bow is kind of
kooks underneath the strings oh and it's
kind of like if you play it poorly
sounds like a mosquito
if you play it well it sounds almost
like somebody's singing
it's very very typical Chinese musical
instrument yeah yeah you'll hear it
myself people playing in Chinatown we
get probably yeah yeah yeah so I found
an R group layer to was named John he
recorded a bunch of improvised stuff
like he was classically trained in are
who in China and so I just showed him
the key that he was in and some of the
chord progressions and he he just
improvised and I took some of it and
chopped it up I did also write some
actual lines for him to play but that
recording process was like all
self-driven I didn't have an engineer
except at the very end to do the final
mix down so I did all that engineering
and the recording and the music
preparation and the production and all
that stuff
and I think the result was fantastic I
was very happy with how it turned out
especially the synthesis of all the
different team members ability is like
all coming together into this one
coherent whole yeah super beautiful so a
below key yeah check that out as well
that links in the bio it's cool to be
able to make music for VR games now as
well the adaptive music technologies
have been I have I have another question
that I think is really important to ask
what are your thoughts on music's
relationship to consciousness and
spirituality
I think that's a super individualistic
question everybody probably has a
different relationship to music
spiritually I am 50% skeptic and 50%
crazy about this kind of thing like I
grew up being super super super
analytical so I loved studying how
people relate to music and how like
there are some literal changes that
happen in the brain when you listen to
like drones or music with pulses of
specific durations like half hurst half
Hertz pulse can actually change the the
rhythms of your brainwaves I don't I'm
I'm skeptical about like binaural beats
I don't think there's that much research
about it that like really confirms it so
that's that's kind of pseudoscience but
yeah I mean to me music has always
created emotions and experiences for me
that I can't explain
um and so I just want to explore that
and there are many ways of doing that
whether it's you know jamming with
people or writing meditative music or
writing music that excites or whatever
yeah damn yeah mute the power of music
to just just she just didn't change
emotion within Ron and I were just at
the San Francisco Symphony it started
groving
what did you hear Wow which i coughs key
the what else did we hear ani the opera
singer Lauren Decker oh she was great
Edwyn out water was the conductor they
did pictures at an Exhibition and matcha
Slava
yep and prom prom prom prom an idols in
pictures of an exposition every movement
did they go back into that piece is that
whether that's Mazursky right yes yeah
it was so good and then that but plus
Ron and I will occasionally in the
studio just throw on a song like what
are we throw on of it la la la la la the
old school song and like from like the
two from 2000 or whatever all tb8 all
around the world
Oh a TV they TV and kids length of the
song or sweet that's that's they that
they're the trance that trance group
right yes yeah yeah yeah they crushed it
yeah the song called don't stop that I
used to listen to all those CC so you
know these things not not too long we
don't want to get copyrights right no
really short um but so that and then
it's just crazy how Ron and I just by
turning it on we were just both like oh
my gosh it's been so long or whole
body's changed you know that that's such
a profound thing that music can do to
humans and when you do it on like a
meditative rock Ron we're currently
being interestingly coming out by
picking universities interested to have
us go out there to do interval school
and so Ron just started playing music
like from China and in the studio and it
was doing some straight-up subconscious
programming for me getting me ready and
I found one track that he played I think
it was once upon it
I'm this really just like like nature +
string instruments and anyway I've been
listening to that well and it's just
like it just changes you it connects you
do music has the potential also to kind
of like tune us to our divine alignment
with what our purpose is to our to
mother to the source fair I love that
about music I think I think everybody
has their own vocabulary to describe
what music does and that's not to say
anybody's particular belief system or
vocabulary is wrong it's just different
ways of accessing sort of the same
underlying trance concepts
yeah so yeah but yeah I mean there there
are emotions that music can induce that
are not in line with anything that
exists outside of listening to music
like there are certain songs that I feel
a specific way and I can't say okay I
feel happy I feel melancholy it's like
an artificial emotion that only comes
from listening to a specific type of
music which i I've never heard anybody
really describe anything like that
before I'd love to hear if anybody has
research yeah on some moods like that
music has the potential for unity which
we showed absolutely was all that was
the gig that was another thing that I
was there was
the lecture that I went to the other
night the lecturer said that
there are studies and chimpanzees that
vocalizations and social grooming can
bind together a group of maybe six to
eight chimpanzees right yeah I was like
us already and in humans our own
specific vocabulary and are like
subcultural like culture can bind
together 15 or 20 people but music were
singing along to something can bind
together thousands and thousands of
people hundreds thousands across the
planet all together yeah same tie so
huge potential yeah and that goes back
to what I was saying earlier that music
brings people together and I think
that's probably one of the most
important things about it and it was so
funny because Mario Garvey audio is just
on the show and he was telling us about
how food brings people together around
the table it's so great how food music
all these things sharing educational
experiences together have the potential
to bring us together and we we got to
really do that moving forward into this
crazy exponential technology
geopolitical move
hodgepodge of mayhem yes yeah the
hodgepodge of may have that's my next
metal band
we gave you a before we started cosmic
archaeology cosmic archaea we hope to
hear that I keep I keep a running list
of like names for pieces because I'm
writing all the time and I don't have we
always have a good name for pieces so
cosmic what was it something mayhem we
just oh I'll write it down for now
Oliver my do
all right let's ask you two questions on
the way out first question is are we in
the simulation potentially I mean is
that verifiable is that a falsifiable
statement no are we ever gonna know
maybe I don't know at this point we
don't did I mean Elon Musk things were
in a simulation right I've I was like in
high school I I had friends I wanted to
start a cult of symbolism yeah that's a
very deep philosophical question I'm not
sure I'm qualified to comment other than
the fact that the possibility is more
interesting to me than whether or not
it's resolved and
real or not and then how about what is
the most beautiful thing in the world
I would say
sound I would say creativity I would say
diversity yeah
art in general expression I think
expression personal self-expression is
probably the most beautiful thing in the
world yeah that's so good I love it this
has been super fun yeah it's been
awesome thank you so much for coming on
and absolutely at all this fresh
pleasure thank you
can we go out with one of your tracks
and usually I'll start yelling in the
Yantra let's play a little I'll bring it
underneath a little chocolate chip also
did you did you mention better off alone
earlier when we were talking to the
trance track Alice DJ was that young yet
everyone okay just roll the truck
nevermind sorry I think you ma'am maybe
but okay okay all right
I imagine may have the Hodge Project
Mayhem love it I love it that one's
gonna stick with me forever okay good
good cult of symbolism there's so many
good ones in there cosmic archaeology
okay so we're closing with chocolate
chip cookie dough again that's on the
soundcloud again that soundcloud.com
floor say this is a stock a stock track
that I wrote it was originally gonna be
a pop song but then I decided to finish
it and submit it for television
opportunities so you know if there's a
ice-cream store out there that needs a
theme song that's the the use case for
this one there's so much diverse economy
youthful things was diversity love that
so much diverse music on there check it
out everyone huge shout out thank you
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode talked
more about music production talked more
about things like adaptive music about
everything from video game soundtracks
instrumentals film scores pop music all
this different type of stuff virtual
reality the future of that as well get
talking about that more with friends
families co-workers people online social
media give us thoughts in the comments
also check out the links in the bio
that's an eco-car log music comm
SoundCloud Nico Cora logs end of the
low-key calm
Charlotte around Vargas for producing
and directing thank you very much Ronnie
and support the artist entrepreneur
the spiritual leaders organizations
around the world that you believe and
support them help them grow sports
simulation our links are below patreon
PayPal cryptocurrencies all below also
design cool merch and get paid that link
is below as well and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world you love you very much
thanks for tuning in and we will see you
soon peace
[Music]